hey youtubers is Charlie so it was just
revealed that Hugo Strange is gonna be
one of the big villains on Gotham this
season and as a result they're gonna
deal a lot with the origins of Arkham
Asylum the way they describe those two
things was very codependent which I
suppose is appropriate given that Hugo
Strange is a psychologist so this video
is gonna be a breakdown of his character
along with the history of Arkham Asylum
we also may have just seen our first
shot of who the Joker is gonna be so
I'll talk about that at the end of the
video hello any new people if you're
just finding me for the first time I do
weekly Marvel and DC videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there's a bunch of crazy comic-con stuff
happening but I'm gonna be doing weekly
episode videos whatever Gotham gets here
so let's explain what's going on with
season 1 it's an origin story for Gotham
City
the gotham city of adult batman so a lot
of places like arkham asylum are being
developed the way you develop a young
Bruce Wayne into Batman so season 1 is
going to explain how Arkham started to
turn into a revolving door for super
criminals
Hugo Strange is a big part of that just
to be clear though just like on arrow
and the flash they're gonna tell their
version of Arkham so it will be a little
different from the comics over the years
Hugo Strange has had a lot of different
roles based on the continuity in the
comics the show is just gonna make all
that a lot more linear so here's a quick
history of Arkham and then I'll explain
how Hugo Strange fits in and then I'll
explain the Joker stuff there's actually
this really cool quote about Arkham from
Jeremiah Arkham the current
administrator Arkham Asylum is not just
any institution for the criminally
insane
it's the Ivy League of insanity a
Harvard for psychopaths the name Arkham
was actually inspired by HP Lovecraft in
his stories he has a fictional town
called arkham massachusetts in the
batman universe it was created by
Amadeus Arkham in the late 1800s after
he helped his mother commit assisted
suicide so the name started out as
Arkham Hospital and then changed to
Arkham Asylum
he became the tradition of Arkham
doctors going insane and ending up as
inmates themselves which actually became
pretty common if the show were to do his
character he's like the spitting image
of Robert Englund
although I suppose Robert Englund could
also play Hugo Strange something about
villains and creepy beards so whenever
he died he passed on custodianship to
his nephew Jeremiah strange the current
administrator who hired several notable
people including doctors Harley Quinzel
Jonathan crane Hugo Strange
who's our Gotham TV show villain
and then liable Tintin all of whom
though went very insane while working
they're going on to become very
memorable villains although Lyle Bolton
wasn't super memorable but Harley Quinn
and scarecrow I mean you got to give it
to them whenever Jeremiah took over
Arkham he actually had the structure
renovated to look much more like a
classical labyrinth totally creepy I
cannot imagine why all those doctors
went insane working in a hospital to
look like a labyrinth right now Arkham
is mostly known for the video game
franchise which is awesome I know a lot
of you guys want me to do videos for
that I might whenever the next one comes
out next year in 2015 there's actually a
lot of Arkham centric comic books if
you're looking for some really good
nightmares including Arkham Asylum
living hell and Arkham Asylum serious
house
on serious earth or you could just read
HP Lovecraft and go straight to the
source
praise Cthulhu so Hugo Strange was
mentioned as a doctor there for a while
but his history in the comics actually
got retcon several times so it's a
little confusing he was raised in an
orphanage in Gotham's version of Hell's
Kitchen that's just a really shitty part
of New York until Rudy Giuliani cleaned
it up he went on to become a brilliant
professor at Gotham University but got
kicked out after they found him
conducting really bizarre genetic
experiments he turns to the mob for
funding to further his research and
starts experimenting on Arkham inmates
he ends up building an army of monster
men and uses them to steal a bunch of
money until Batman stops him obviously
on the show you can see fish Mooney the
role the mobster played by Jada Pinkett
Smith later stories took him down more
of a scarecrow path with more
psychological compounds think like
scarecrow in Dark Knight trilogy in his
fear compound in another story much much
later he was actually hired by Gordon to
be a consultant with the police
department he ended up going crazy and
Batman took him down but it's just
another way that the show could use him
the Riddler character on the show is
actually a forensic scientist in
Gordon's department that's actually the
same job that grant gustin's flash
character has on his show it's just a
funny coincidence and his core he's just
a brilliant but incredibly insane
psychologist and scientists completely
obsessed with Batman he's mostly known
as one of the few people who ever
correctly deduced Batman's true identity
that story was the one that they used
whenever he showed up on the animated
series the classic animated series so
you get the picture most of the stories
that he gets used in involved warping
people's minds especially Batman's
which is perfect for television it's a
lot cheaper to have a villain manipulate
people's thoughts and emotions than to
have Bain blow up half the city every
week because Bruce Wayne is a child on
the show and Hugo Strange is gonna be an
adult it's possible they could introduce
him as his psychologist to help him get
over his parents murder if you want to
read some good Hugo Strange stories read
Batman pray Batman
transference and Catwoman the one you
love
so whenever the show picks up
essentially we're gonna be looking at
Gotham City at the beginning of its slow
descent into madness so we're just gonna
be watching things go to for the
next five years which is actually pretty
exciting the biggest criticism of the
pilot I've seen so far is that it just
makes a lot of promises in terms of
characters and comic-book stories that
it may never get to pay off Arkham
Asylum is essentially gonna be like
their Pandora's box of villains because
the way it's set up in the Canon you can
essentially just pull any villain you
want out of there
another big villain that's unofficially
confirmed is the Joker this is a screen
cap of the actor John Bevers he plays
the comedian working in fish Mooney's
club it's believed he's going to be the
character that they turn into the Joker
eventually his credit just reads as
comedian but I definitely think that
it's him they just need a season or two
to develop that persona he's barely even
in the pilot so he's not gonna be the
big focus of the show right now it's
like they're setting a laughing gas bomb
to explode in like 20 or 30 episodes
speaking of the other characters arrow
is starting to take a giant bite out of
the Batman universe in terms of side
characters in response to all the new
stuff that arrow is doing that Gotham
producers made it really clear that they
didn't think that arrow is gonna be
taking characters from them despite
Stephen Amell making an offhand remark
that you know if you really like Batman
villains you're gonna love arrow season
3 it is a little confusing about how
both shows are gonna handle everything
going forward but because they seem like
they want to cooperate don't rule out
crossovers that kind of thing requires
approval at the network level especially
between two different networks so the
producers if they're gonna do something
like that will apply it to sacrifice an
animal to some sort of pagan god if you
really want to see how good crossovers
can be when they're done well watch
arrow and the flash this fall here's all
the premiere dates for the DC shows
first starter is Gotham that's Monday
September 22nd
then there's the flash Tuesday October
7th arrow the next day on October 8th
then Constantine Friday October 24th
they're gonna be screening all of the
first episodes of all those shows at
Comic Con I'll be doing reviews for all
of them be sure to subscribe to get all
those they're not gonna be screening
that Gotham palate till Saturday so my
review that won't post til Sunday right
now click here to learn about the other
villains that we're gonna be seeing on
Gotham pretty soon including mr. freeze
and click here to learn all about what's
happening that first episode of arrow
season 3 thanks so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives